i'm here with Grandmaster fabiano
caruana and you had a draw today I was
in the live Cameron commentary room and
Julian Hodgson yelled when you played
Bishop to g5 was that your intended
effect uh actually I told him before the
game that he would like to opening but
he thought I was being sarcastic you've
really thought I meant it it'll be
another rule in um yeah I just I wanted
to get something else I was tired of
playing the same opening every game is
it something you um had thought of
yesterday like when did you come up with
the idea to play this against Gary yeah
I decided to played yesterday um
basically just lay tonight you probably
you know yesterday when we asked people
about whose laptop they would borrow for
an hour Grisha you and Gary were like
the top backs is it partly because of
respect for his opening analysis that
you picked such an offbeat line uh well
Ani she was very well prepared and very
knowledgeable and um pretty much every
line he has a very solid repertoire so I
thought that at least I'd be able to get
a game and I did manage to get a game I
thought I had some serious chances for
an advantage at some point and where did
you did you get that notion to spell um
after Queen c5 I at first i thought i
would have something but I just
gradually dawned on me that that's very
difficult to do anything to keep my pawn
I was trying to lose like queen bee 594
and I at some point I realized I'm just
I might get worse if if I start making
strange maneuver so I thought maybe in
the game I have a little something but
turned out it wasn't much do you we
expect more time pass keys out of you
now uh I can't say that all right thank
you very much with fabiano caruana today
drawing against unease Gary